D
GREG GUTFELD WEARING A T-SHIRT.
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
♪ ♪
>> Jesse: THE CONSEQUENCES OF
DEFUNDING THE POLICE ARE LEADING
TO ANARCHY IN AMERICA.
COPS ARE UNDER ATTACK WHILE
CRIMES URGES ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
AFTER PORTLAND WAS BATTERED WITH
A YEAR OF RIOTS AND ENTIRE SQUAD
IS NOW RESIGNING.
THE POLICE DEPARTMENT 51ST AND
CROWD CONTROL UNIT IS STEPPING
DOWN AFTER ONE OFFICER WAS
INDICTED FOR USING EXCESSIVE
FORCE DURING THE UNREST LAST
YEAR.
AND LOOK AT THIS INSANE CRIME
SURGE IN PORTLAND.
SHOOTINGS ARE UP 126% AND
HOMICIDES HAVE INCREASED 530%.
THAT IS A LOT.
OTHER MAJOR CITIES LIKE NEW YORK
AND CHICAGO ARE SEEING A
DRAMATIC INCREASE IN VIOLENCE
THANKS TO LIBERAL POLICIES AND
CRIMINALS ARE MORE BRAZEN THAN
EVER.
THE NYPD JUST PUT OUT A VIDEO OF
A MAN GETTING GUNNED DOWN IN
BROAD DAYLIGHT AFTER RUNNING
INTO TWO YOUNG CHILDREN ON THE
SIDEWALK.
THANKFULLY THE CHILDREN ARE
UNHARMED AND THE CHILDREN ARE
EXPECTED TO SURVIVE.
DEMOCRATS, LIKE THIS POLITICIAN
IN THE WINDY CITY.
>> THE PROBLEM IS, THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY ON SO MANY
LEVELS SEEMS TO BE ENAMORED WITH
THE MENTALITY OF BEING ENABLERS
TO CRIMINALITY, AND YOU DON'T
HAVE TO SAY IDENTITY POLITICS,
SOMETIMES VOTERS JUST WANT THE
TRUTH.
>> Jesse: LET'S GET THIS OUT
OF THE WAY, GREG, WHERE CAN
PEOPLE GET THE T-SHIRT?
>> Greg: YOU CAN GET IT AT THE
STORE.
THE FOX SHOP.
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY HAVE THE
MEN YET BUT I GOT THE FIRST ONE
SO I THOUGHT I WOULD WEAR IT.
>> Jesse: WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
CRIME, THAT IS A FASHION CRIME,
BUT JESSICA PROBABLY WON'T DO
ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
>> I'M ENJOYING IT, ACTUALLY.
>> Jesse: TELL ME WHAT YOU
THINK ABOUT THIS GUY FROM THE
WINDY CITY OF CHICAGO, FOR THOSE
OF YOU WHO DON'T KNOW THAT, HE
SANG DEMOCRATS NEED TO CODDLE UP
TO CRIMINALS TO WIN ELECTIONS.
>> Greg: I THINK THERE'S TWO
THINGS GOING ON HERE.
NUMBER ONE, DEMOCRATS DON'T LIKE
TO BE SEEN TAKING THE SIDE OF
THE OPPOSITION, EVEN IF THE
OPPOSITION IS RIGHT AND I WOULD
SAY SOMETIMES REPUBLICANS ARE
LIKE THAT AS WELL BUT IN THIS
CASE THERE IS SUCH OVERWHELMING
EVIDENCE THAT PEOPLE ARE DYING
BECAUSE OF YOUR EGO AND BECAUSE
YOU DON'T WANT TO ALIGN YOURSELF
WITH SOMEBODY YOU THINK IS AN
IMMORAL, EVIL REPUBLICAN.
I JUST WANT TO COME UP WITH ONE
CITY IN WHICH THERE IS A
REPUBLICAN MAYOR AND THERE IS
TROUBLE, BECAUSE I SPENT ALL
NIGHT WORKING AT THE LIBRARY,
THE FOX LIBRARY.
I COULDN'T FIND ONE EXAMPLE OF A
REPUBLICAN MAYOR LEADING A CITY
THAT IS IN TROUBLE.
THE OTHER POINT IS THE BIGGEST
THREAT ACCORDING TO
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS THE WHITE
SUPREMACIST MOVEMENT YET WE
STILL DON'T HAVE THE STATS FOR
THAT, WE DON'T HAVE THE NAMES OR
THE ORGANIZED CRIME GANGS
CAUSING CRIME SPREES IN THE NAME
OF WHITE SUPREMACY AND YET WE
KNOW THE NAMES OF THE CLOWNS IN
OREGON.
IT'S CALLED ANTIFA AND THEY TELL
US WHERE THEY ARE.
PORTLAND.
AND YET THAT IS CALLED AN IDEA
WHEN IT'S ACTUALLY A VIOLENT MOB
THAT IS DESTROYING A CITY.
BASICALLY WHAT WE'RE DOING DOING
IS GIVING BAD ACTORS WHAT THEY
WANT BY DENYING THEY EXIST WHILE
CHASING THIS PHANTOM OF WHITE
SUPREMACY AND THIS IS A REPLICA
OF EVERY BLOODY REVOLUTION.
YOU START, WHEN A POPULATION
GIVES INTO AN IMMOVABLE
MINORITY, MEANING A SMALL NUMBER
OF PEOPLE, DO WE KNOW HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE IN ANTIFA?
WE DON'T, DO WE?
IT'S JUST AN IDEA.
I BET YOU COULD FIT THEM IN AN
AUDITORIUM.
>> Jesse: YOU COULD BECAUSE
THEY GO FROM CITY TO CITY AND I
DON'T KNOW IF THEY'VE BEEN
INFILTRATED BY THE FBI.
>> Greg: TRAVELING CARDINAL.
>> Jesse: THIS UNIT HAS
RETIRED EN MASSE.
IS THIS ENOUGH FOR POLITICIANS
TO SNAP OUT OF THEIR DAYS?
>> Kennedy: THERE'S THIS
WIDESPREAD BLANKET -- OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT IN PORTLAND.
I FEEL COMPLETELY UNPROTECTED
AND ATTACKED BY THE VERY LOCAL
MINORITY IN THE CITY AND THE
D.A. THERE, MIKE SCHMIDT, HE IS
AWFUL.
I TALKED TO MY BROTHER, I TALK
ABOUT MY BROTHER A LOT, HE IS A
COP OUTSIDE PORTLAND, WAS A
PROBATION OFFICER FOR YEARS, AND
HE IS A SHOOTING INSTRUCTOR AT
THE OREGON STATE POLICE ACADEMY,
SO WE TALK ALL THE TIME AND HE
SAYS THAT PROACTIVE POLICING
WILL GO ON THE DECLINE THIS
YEAR.
COPS ARE GOING TO BE LIKE
FIREFIGHTERS, THEY WILL ONLY
RESPOND WHEN SOMETHING BAD
HAPPENS INSTEAD OF GOING OUT,
TALKING TO PEOPLE, ENGAGING,
STOPPING STUFF BEFORE IT STARTS
BECAUSE FOR THEM IT IS NOT WORTH
IT TO GET INDICTED AND IT JUST
GOES TO SHOW, THIS SORT OF
REVOLT, THEY ARE STANDING UP TO
THEM MAYOR AND A D.A. WHO DOES
NOT HAVE THEIR BACK, THEY WILL
NOT INDICT AGGRESSIVE CRIMINAL
FELONS WHO ARE MAKING THE CITY
VERY UNFREE.
>> Greg: DID YOU SAY NOT LESS?
>> Kennedy: I DID.
>> Jesse: IT'S AN ALLERGY.
AND CHILDREN ARE GETTING CAUGHT
IN THE CROSS FIRE.
THANK GOD THEY ARE OKAY BUT A
STRAY BULLET, GOODBYE, YOUR LIFE
IS OVER AND YOUR PARENTS HAVE TO
PICK UP THE PIECES.
>> Dagen: AND PRO CRIME,
ANTI-LAW ENFORCEMENT RESIDENTS
AND VICTIMS HAVE TO FEND FOR
THEMSELVES.
IT STARTS WITH THE GOVERNOR, AND
LOOK HERE IN NEW YORK, THIS IS
CUOMO DOWN TO THE MAYOR, THE
CITY COUNCIL, THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS WHO HAVE DEMONIZED,
NOT ONLY DEMONIZED, WHICH IS THE
SAME EFFECT AS DEFUNDING THE
POLICE BECAUSE IT MAKES THEM
STEP BACK AND PEOPLE RETIRE BUT
ALSO, THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR
YEARS, THAT LAWS AND CHANGES TO
THE BOOK THAT HAVE LED PEOPLE
FREE ONTO THE STREET, A COUPLE
OF THINGS.
I TALKED HER COPS ALL THE TIME
IN THE STREET AND I ASK THEM,
HOW AM I SUPPOSED TO DEFEND
MYSELF?
STRICT GUN LAWS HERE, WHAT AM I
SUPPOSED TO DO?